[Applause]
here's something that i saw that i
actually have no proof to if it's real
or not but it was going around twitter
and i've heard a few conversations about
this male virginity
on the rise yes you were a virgin most
of your life most of my life
what are your thoughts i wish i was born
10 years later you know what i mean
i wouldn't have seemed so freakish my
whole life i'd had more friends
no i don't know if i believe it but i
also can see how you're just you just
have porn
all the time these guys don't know how
to talk to girls they weren't trained to
like deal with rejection you're just
like i'll just jerk off watch all the
point i want not chill
but isn't it weird that as it's become
monumentally easier to get [__] meaning
like you can literally swipe [__] into
your house
right yeah so much easier to meet girls
like yeah the dating app they'll talk to
you first now they talk to you first
what is the name of that app bumble
bumble yeah so it's like
the most terrifying thing about meeting
a girl is public humiliation
at least when we were growing up right
getting humiliated in front of your
friends
now they've eliminated public
humiliation yeah you are humiliated but
in the privacy of your own phone
nobody sees that humiliation you end up
connecting with the people that work
it's like
it's baffling to me as we've made things
easier
they've become harder like maybe we
shouldn't be making things easier
maybe we need to work those [__]
muscles and maybe when we let muscles
atrophy we're actually limiting our
ability like
it worked great for those of us who
learned how to get [__]
the hard way and then it became easier
right but the [__] who never
learned the hard way
never built up the muscle yeah it's like
you had on ankle weights you had to hit
on girls in real life yeah then you took
off the ankle weights and now it's just
messages online shooting fish in a
barrel these [__] got no ankles
they got no ankles it's like the uh what
do they always say like the uh
the son of the king is always gonna lose
the throne
because he never had to earn it yeah in
the first place okay is that a quote
it's something about like it's like uh
like the king the king that had to
actually win the throne through like
war uh he wanted it he won it right
whereas the one who just gets it through
nepotism
never had to earn it so he doesn't
actually know how to rule people
yeah he's just a spoiled little [__]
right and i wonder if that's what we're
raising this generation to spoil a
little [__] we thought we were just
gonna make it easier to get laid when in
reality
they need to put the work in yeah yeah i
could see it being harder because one
i think even women are getting way more
shallow because now they just like have
these oh if you're not over six foot
don't even swipe on me and [__] like
that
oh [__] and
and so oh [__] like that now you can't
even like
go out on dates to meet these oh my god
al you just said something super [__]
profound
i didn't even think about this the idea
that now that dating apps are purely
digital it is a meat market
yeah and could this be what makes guys
start
waxing their eyebrows makes guys start
using like almost makeup-esque things
like really leaning into their looks and
the way women have leaned into their
looks because women knew that their
looks were currency at least to meet
the opposite sex so now guys know that
the only way
i'm going to be able to get laid is if i
look good
on this app i need to make sure the meat
looks good if i'm at a grocery store you
know how the vegetables and fruits
always look
way more delicious when you're in the
store because they put the nice lights
on it yeah they're spraying water every
once in a while
are guys going to start leaning into
their looks in a way they never had to
before because they know that's what
it's going to take and do they start
leaning away from their personality
and leaning away from their success
they're like oh i could get [__] if i
just look good
i and not because i'm uh successful or
wealthy
and not because i'm necessarily charming
i just have to look well i think you
still have to charm the [__]
but you might they might start investing
in things that are not the traditional
matrix yeah
within the traditional matrix that we
used to get laid which is success
i'll be successful these girls want to
be a successful dude okay we got it
what are you saying you'll lose you'll
lose money chasing women you'll never
lose women chasing money
yeah that's a fire assay yeah that's
that's the thing that they just used to
always say to us now might not be so
true
now hey these [__] make more than you
anyway bro that's
crazy that is crazy and i wonder if that
is the catalyst for guys
being super feminine about their looks
like we already went through that as i
said here with my legs crossed but like
we already went through that stage i
think where guys start you know we're
being critical
of of other dudes for being too feminine
right metrosexual yeah the metrosexual
stage and they're like maybe doing
things
to manicure themselves in a way that
maybe the traditional dude
wouldn't support yeah but now i feel
like we could enter a stage where they
might be starting to use filters and
makeup
yeah or they go the other way just
become full insults which is what this
might also be
yeah and they get angsty and frustrated
and pissed off because that's the other
thing i'm reading this article about the
male virginity thing
is that they're saying that women's
market has increased so much
like if you're like a 19 20 year old
girl like back in the day your market
for who you could have sex with was like
your college
community people in your math class that
sort of thing but now you can access
35 year old dudes like 40 year old dudes
at the bars like
all of a sudden you're you get to choose
your pool is so much bigger whereas like
guys
like they're they don't necessarily have
the choice and they had
a protected pool this was really
interesting i noticed this when i was in
college and there was a sorority
fraternity thing
and there wasn't like an actual
statement made
but like the sorority chicks and
fraternity dudes kind of [__] each
other
yeah and that's how it always was and
that was a structure that was set up
for success for both of them you pick
within these different groups
the outsiders don't really tap into
those groups
and we keep our parties somewhat
i guess homogeneous for lack of a better
word and this way a dude who doesn't
have much value in the free market
has a lot of value if he's attached this
fraternity that is valuable
right yeah it's almost like the
hollywood setup yeah in a way right
i guess all structures no that's
happening now in hollywood with tick
tock content houses those are the
that's the high school structure so then
you have this situation where
a guy could siphon off value
from the frat that he was in and girls i
guess could siphon off value from
the sororities that they were in right
and ah it's so interesting man yeah but
now
like if you're pool if you're like a 22
year old girl in college like now you
can
date the entire world as a 22 where
there wasn't access to the entire world
yes there was if you went to nightclubs
and that kind of stuff which they did
like girls that were 22
it was not lost upon them that they
could date whatever guy that they wanted
i don't think girls just started
realizing i can [__] old guys in terms
of access though yeah there was
i think there was as much access in
terms of um going out to nightclubs i
mean that's what was that nice
girls went to nightclubs now every girl
has these apps
i think they would all go to nightclubs
now i don't know
i would not go out but i agree with you
there's definitely more people
and you're not just dealing with
nightclub douchebags you're dealing with
like
a guy who's 35 he's got a good job yeah
and he's posing pictures from his car
he's posing pictures of him skiing
you're like oh wow this guy's going this
is
interesting he's like he's mature he's
older he's got a career
why am i going to waste time with this
great [__] 22 year old
these 22 year olds don't have a [__]
shot in hell
unless they're popular on tick tock or
something like that thanks because girls
are maturing older than guys anyway
already so they're like yeah i want a
guy that's mature and
professional and got a ship figured i
like nice bags this guy can actually buy
my bag i mean it sucks for me to just
chalk
women up to that but like there might be
some thinking and these like shallow
chicks well the things that we
you wanted to get successful to get
chicks these guys are already successful
and now these chicks have access to
those successful guys which is i think
actually kind of how it was historically
for a long time
like way back in the day like 1700s like
you were
you know 17 year old girl getting
married to a 35 year old guy
yeah but like i think communities of
course yeah but like communities were
much smaller
right exactly right like and it was
often arranged and things like that
exactly yeah so so you had this small
dating pool and it kind of functioned
within that small dating pool because
everybody there was a hierarchy
established within that pool
right now you're dating the whole world
like these literal apps you can go on
apps and then match with people in
[__] australia
yeah like that's crazy yeah so now as a
young dude
you're competing with older guys who
women do not have any issue with dating
older
if anything they prefer it yeah right so
you're at a disadvantage
it's it's not like um if you're a girl
and you're older there's a disadvantage
because guys might prefer a younger girl
right like if there's a guy who's 30
years old he might want to date a girl
who's 25
not 30. yeah right and for not even
shallow reasons biological reasons
biological ones yeah if he wants to have
five kids and doesn't want to start
making those kids for another five years
it ain't happening with that 35 year old
yeah
wow man so it makes sense so you believe
in this virginity thing you think that
it's real
i think also a possibility i think
that's all true i think another factor
could be
you i've heard kids don't drink as much
they don't do as many drugs now and
it's just because they have dopamine
whenever they want right here
so they just are always kind of like oh
i'm good i got my little dopamine hit
i'm good i don't need that as much as i
usually i thought kids were doing way
more drugs
i think some kids are doing way more but
i think overall there's a lot more kids
that aren't drinking
aren't doing anything when i was in
college there are people that did
cocaine
but it was taboo still yeah now cocaine
has become a party drug in my generation
it's become like a
oh we're going out tonight might as well
do some cocaine for kids yeah yes
i mean like college like late high
school late high school
like but they treat it like taking a
puff of weed yeah like you wanna do some
coke yeah i guess i'm i'm already out
i'm having a few drinks
actually i've heard the same this was if
you did coke it was like this is what
we're doing tonight we're doing some
coke tonight did you find a way to get
some coat like it was
it was almost dangerous you're like we
could get we'd go to jail if we didn't i
didn't even see anybody doing coke until
i was in new york in my mid-twenties
yeah
you didn't also see labia yeah early
30s that's a valid point yeah
there's a couple other things that the
article mentions is like marriage rates
going down
so like back in the day this is like
this i see yeah if you were 18 getting
married because you're in a community
and you're like you're going to have sex
at 18 because that's what it is dude
what's
so bad for these young boys yeah
apparently sexlessness and they're not
gonna get
sex until they become successful so
yeah this this been there done that
no but this tapped into like i used to
have a like a joke i didn't even really
do the joke per se
but like a premise about uh um
about there's no terrorism like uh in
puerto rico
you know what i mean it's like because
[__] are getting [__] you know
what i mean like
like you getting [__] at 15 years old
14 years old people are [__]
whenever they're [__] there's no
terrorism right and we always talk about
like
who's the greatest domestic terrorist oh
like domestic terrorism yeah i'm talking
about like
like there's not getting [__] say what
dude's not getting pushed who's not
getting [__] right and that [__] ain't
happening in the middle east
[__] not getting any [__]
and they're like yo we got all this
[__] when you dead you ready to risk it
not only that ireland people always want
to talk about yeah you want to you come
from like a strict
conflict maybe right you were coming
super you reluctantly gave that up
maybe fine you know
um i think there could have been
something out there if it was a super
strict
catholic country where you're a little
bit repressed when it comes to your like
sexual desires
in the dominican republic you're not
going to find any of this terrorism
maybe there's like narco terrorism which
is completely drug-related not really
from not getting no [__] [__]
you know but any of these places where
you're allowed to actually [__] where
you got some [__] to look forward to
you're not blowing up no [__]
building apparently i don't know if i've
i brought this up before but
there was a actual like a psychological
war tactic done in iraq
where like oh they dropped [__] porn
yeah they were like putting porn into
the homes where like they were like
putting it through like the airwaves
yeah like late at night if you want to
like tune in
it wasn't like broadcasting your face
but if you want to go to a channel and
watch porn
it used to never be accessible and now
it was but why'd they do that
so they could see women without
mustaches and they thought that would
end the war they thought if they saw a
woman without a full mustache and beard
and also a unibrow
that they would go no this is right am i
morgan why did you do that
i mean like the theory is that it was
able to like sedate the men
and that like they weren't as eager to
be out there you know killing and [__]
when they're able to you know did it
work ah
so if you just keep them at home
whacking off they'll not go outside and
do project pink didn't work
yeah i don't know exactly i mean we're
still in a rack dude
we need to start dropping women over
there yeah what's the point for
you